That you got an opportunity here,
your,
your mentor disappears for long stretches.
Good. Let him go take a
long lunch boss. I got it.
Oh you want to assign me these
menial tasks will eventually he,
if he's going to take all of these breaks,
then he's going to have you
do the more meaningful work.
So that's fine. Um, you, you
can do better work than him.
Good.
That's going to be fine.
That's going to show through eventually
he's well connected up the chain of
command. Beautiful. Beautiful.
Cause if you can now build
a relationship with him,
you're going to be well connected to
and that's going to be the hardest part,
right?
The heart that's gonna be,
it's gonna be hard to do
and it's especially hard
to do because your attitude
right now is negative, right? Your
attitude right now is negative.
It's a little ego kicking in.
I can do better than him. He's,
I'm under utilized.
He's has,
he does things or he's making me
do things beneath my capabilities.
So those were all just ego. It's
fine. You go, there's a good, he goes,
got a lot of positives to it may be
what's driving you to want to do better.
So it's okay,
but you're going to have to
overcome that in this scenario,
in order to build a
relationship with this guy, man,
I built relationships with guys
that I hated.
You know, I mean, cause guess what? Does
that make me too faced? No, you know what?
It's my job. I'm a professional. I
am a professional. I guarantee you,
you come and work with me.
You will see I am a professional and
yet I will build relationships. So,
so not,
and yet,
but so that means my job
and my professionalism is
more important than my ego
and my, and my, uh,
my create a calorie of other people,
right? I'm not looking down on him going,
I'm so, cause what I wanna do
is build a good relationship.
So when we build that good
relationship with him, now he's,
if he's well connected with the
folks up top, they're like, oh,
what's up with Billy? All Billy's good
to go, man, he's doing a great job. Now,
what if you're like, well,
the thing that the other,
so once you got to be careful of what
you don't want to do is create an
antagonistic relationship with them.
And that includes threatening
him with your work ethic,
threatening him with
your performance level,
threatening him with your skills so
you almost have to throttle back just a
little bit enough that
he's not threatened.
Now the other thing you can do instead
of throttling back is what you do is you
give them the credit, the credit, and
you give him the credit and you're good,
and now he's like a pumped.
He's not looking at you become you.
Build the relationship.
That's what we want to do.
We want to build a relationship and
we want to put your ego in check.
Do the little menial tasks.
Learn as much as you can and let me tell
you all this is you will rise to the
top. If you do it right, you will
rise to the top. If you screw it up,
you will never rise.
If you create an antibiotic
antagonistic relationship with him,
you will not promote. You
will not. If you do it right,
you will end up above him in the
chain of command. It will take time.
It will take swallowing of pride,
but it will happen. It might take
five years. It might take seven years.
It might take nine months.
I don't know.
But that's what you have to do to
make it happen and have fun doing it.
If you're going to go crazy every day,
if it hurts you so bad,
I make a game out of it.
I mean,
I'm going to make a total game out
of it where my goal is to build this
relationship with this guy.
I'm going to make a game out of it.
We're going to have fun with it.
I'm not going to be angry when I
come home from work and go, God,
I can't believe I had to shake his
hand. No, I'm going to come back like,
you know what? Hey plug. Talked
to my wife was a, Hey, guess what?
He actually bought me lunch today and we
were laughing about the football game.
I don't even like football. You know what
I mean? I'm gonna, I'm gonna build that.
And I'm going to win.
And in the long run you're guaranteed
to win if you can play that game. So
again, everyone thinks it's going
to be like are you, does not me.
Cause I was in the military,
you just not meet the standards.
What you do is you smash him and
report them up the chain of command.
Oh that good luck with that.
You have this guy as well connected and
has relationships with Amy where they're
going to go and look.
Shut up. New Guy. Yeah.
Cause you're actually proving not only,
you're actually proving when you do this,
you're actually proving that you're not
a good leader and that you can't put
your ego in check.
You're proving that you can't,
you're proving that you can't work with
some people. We have that Guy Yo Jocko,
he, oh add Taco can't work with
anybody. Junk was really good.
As long as he's working with, you
know his team. So what does that mean?
It means you're confined for the rest
of your life of only working with your
team. Yup. Whereas if it's, hey, Jocko was
good to go, he can work with anybody. Oh,
he worked with bill who is an
EGOMANIAC and he worked with Mike,
who is a lazy bastard. Guess what? It
doesn't matter where you put Jocko.
He's going to get it done. Okay, cool.
That's the attitude we want
people to have about us.